welcome to the show everybody thanks for
watching thank you for listening hope
you had a wonderful weekend I have to
start off the week unfortunately talking
about a a pretty tragic story it's the
story of Alfie Evans and it's important
it's an important story primarily for
for well for two reasons number one
because a little boy's life is at stake
number two secondarily it also gives us
a glimpse into our future we in the
United States we can always look over to
Europe to kind of see where we're headed
to see what it's like looking into a
crystal ball basically and I've always
said that Western culture is is on a
train headed into the abyss and it is
specifically a train not a car or
anything because it's it's Europe is
essentially a few train cars ahead of us
but we're all attached and we're going
in the same direction so just look where
they are and that's what we're gonna be
the only way to avoid it is for us to
detach our train car from theirs and
then go off in a different direction
which obviously is not how it would
actually work with a real train so the
analogy breaks down there but you get
what I'm saying the point is we have not
attached ourselves and so we are going
in the same direction so if you want to
know what our dystopian future looks
like just look at Europe and you can
look there especially with the case of
Alfie Evans who is another sick child
who's been sentenced to death by a UK
death panel first you had the prominent
case of Charlie guard last year and now
we have Alfie Evans and what is becoming
a annual or biannual tradition Alfie
Evans is a baby and he's in a coma due
to a mysterious brain disease that still
has not been diagnosed and nobody knows
exactly what's wrong with him
doctors at alder elder hay Hospital in
London have decided that that Alfie is
not going to get better he's it he's an
irreversible coma a coma
he's not gonna wake up he's effectively
dead already his
life is no longer worth living he's not
even really living a life and so the
only path now is to just attach him from
all the machines and let him die
his parents don't agree now here is the
really crucial thing that we all need to
understand Alfie's parents are not
trying to force the doctors at alder hay
hospital to perform a medical procedure
that they don't want to perform they're
not trying to force the hospital to do
anything and that to me is important
because I think a hospital should have a
fair amount of discretion when it comes
to these things and if they really think
that a certain procedure is not the
right path or if they really believe
according to their own medical opinion
that a person is now brain-dead and
they're not going to recover and that's
it
it would be wrong to keep them alive
physically well then they have to you
know they need to have the ability to
act on on their own conscience and their
own medical opinions or to not act
whatever the case may be the pay that
the families of a patient cannot always
be the final authority in every
individual hospital because if that was
the case then you all across the world
you would have tons of people who are
just being kept alive for no other
reason than the family can't let them go
understandably the family's not able to
let them go so the patient is kept alive
not for the patient's sake but for the
sake of a family member who is who just
doesn't want to see their you know child
or their parent or whoever died so you
can't have that so the hospital's need
to be able to draw a line at some point
and say no we're not going to do that
but alfea's parents they're not trying
to push the hospital over that line all
they're saying is okay you don't want to
do it you don't want to keep him on the
machines fine give him back to us
let us reclaim custody of our own child
he's out of your hands so you don't have
to worry about it give him back to us
and we'll transfer him to a hospital
that thinks it can
treat him as it happens there's a
hospital hospital in Rome that has
already said you know they've already
welcomed the child and they believe that
perhaps they can treat him it was the
same thing with Charlie guard where
Charlie guards parents they had
everything set up they had the money
that I had they had it all set up they
could put charlie guard on a plane and
send him over to the US where there was
a doctor willing to perform some
experimental treatment on him but the
hospital in that case said no you can't
have your own child back and the same
thing is happening again without the
ovens now it may well be true that Alfie
Evans is never going to recover it may
be true that he's now effectively dead
and nothing's gonna bring him back
but but first of all I don't see how the
hospital can argue that on one hand he's
brain dead and on the other hand he's
suffering and it seems like they're
arguing both things that he's suffering
and it's not fair we got to essentially
put him out of his misery
but also he's brain-dead well if he's
brain-dead then he's probably not
suffering so it seems like he got to
choose one of the other but whatever the
case there's nothing to lose by
transferring the child to a hospital
that's willing to treat him I mean I
don't know I you've got the hospital in
London saying one thing you've got the
parents saying another you've got this
hospital in Rome saying yeah maybe we
can treat them so there are a bunch of
different medical opinions I have no
idea who's correct and who isn't all I
know is that it's very common for a
patient to seek a second opinion
and if you were told by a doctor oh
you're gonna die there's nothing we
could do for you well then you certainly
would want to go to it you'd want to go
to at least one other hospital and talk
to one other doctor let them see you
being there care before resigning
yourself to that and if it was your
child in this position in a hospital and
the hospital is saying we got to pull
the plug there's nothing we can do
obviously you'd want to bring him to at
least one
their hospital before giving up and as a
parent you should have that right should
you not have the right to take back your
own child and seek alternative care for
him should you not have the right to
exhaust every possible Avenue before
giving up should you not have the right
to take back your own child from this
hospital
well not in the UK over there children
are the property of the state and of the
medical establishment apparently and the
state has final say over life and death
it's interesting because the death
penalty has long since been abolished
all across Europe but the government can
still impose essentially a death penalty
on the young and the sick it's only
convicted murderers who are free from
those kinds of inhumanities but sick
babies are not so fortunate in fact the
logical the logical conflict is even
worse because you have to consider that
abortion is also legal all across Europe
and in most of the countries although
there are different restrictions and
laws that apply in depending on which
country you're in but the fact remains a
child out of the womb in Europe is
treated as though he is not under the
jurisdiction of his parents and his
rights that is the right to die
exist independent of the parents wishes
but a child in the womb is entirely the
property of the mother and is not even
recognised as another human and has no
rights whatsoever apart from her
although I guess he still has the right
to die that's the only right that he has
which as you noticed the right to die is
very big in Europe they are always
encouraging everyone to explore this
rights and they're always fighting to
protect it and this is why Europe is
dying because there's such big fans of
death but
all that aside I just think we need to
be exceedingly clear about what actually
is at issue when it comes to Alfie Evans
or any similar case no matter how anyone
tries to frame this the dispute is not
over any medical controversy it's not
really about medicine at all because as
I said it doesn't really matter whether
you think Alfie can recover or not
that's not the point the dispute is
really over two simple questions number
one is life sacred and number two to
whom does a child belong now if a
society believes that life is sacred
then there would be a general
understanding that everything within
reason should be done to preserve it but
if life is treated it in this kind of
utilitarian materialist way where it's
only useful or desirable up to a point
then it makes sense to just do away with
Alfie Evans and those like him but
really this is about number two this is
about who has authority over a child the
correct way of thinking about it is this
God is the first supreme authority and
God delegates responsibility and
authority to us he delegates
responsibility for a child first and
primarily to the parent and and that is
a that that's an essential point not
just with this issue but also with
abortion because this is one of the
major reasons why abortion is such a
horrendous evil the first reason is that
you're taking an innocent life but the
second reason is the second reason is
not that while you're infringing on the
child's right to life
I think the second reason that's also a
reason but I think the second reason is
that it's the parent that abortion is
what happens when the parent
this responsibility that has been handed
to them by God and the parent has no
right to do that now they may have the
legal right but they have no moral right
whatsoever and that's why I've long said
that when we talk you know maybe we talk
about rights a little bit too much
especially because the concept of human
rights has become so convoluted and
confused
and nobody even knows what a human right
is anymore certainly most people don't
and you can't look to the courts either
in Europe or in or in the United States
to find out if you look to them you'll
be more confused than you were to begin
with
most people you know they'll go around
all day saying oh I have a right to this
I have a right to that they'll talk
about their rights all day long but if
you were to ask them what is a right and
where does it come from and what does it
mean exactly they wouldn't be able to
even begin to tell you but the reality
is that rights come to us from God but
every right that God gives us is number
one it is not a final it's not it's not
it's not is some sort of like supreme
cosmic right because we have no rights
whatsoever over God he really is the one
who has all the rights in the universe
and so in a certain sense we have none
at least we have none against him but he
does in a sense give us rights but
attached to those rights our
responsibilities every right that we are
given comes attached to a responsibility
and so they're dimensions of the same
thing so it's true that a child has the
right to life it's also true and it's
not said often enough that because of
that right the parent has a
responsibility to that child
and it's respond
ability that you cannot decline legally
you can physically you can but you're
gonna answer for it
so anyway God delegates Authority
delegates authority for a child to the
parents primarily and then to the family
more broadly and then to the state so if
the parents just completely fail to hold
up their end of the bargain and they
abandon their duty and they're abusive
to the child or they're you know a
threat to the child's well-being in some
way then the state has to step in and
temporarily the state becomes the
primary primary authority over the child
the state takes the child into its own
custody but that isn't the case here or
at least it shouldn't be the parents
obviously love their child and are
simply trying to preserve his life they
have not shirked their responsibility
they are trying to carry it out there
being prevented from carrying out their
duty to the child by the state which has
put itself as the supreme authority over
all children and over everyone else
above the parents above God and this I
think reveals not only the problem with
socialized medicine although it does
reveal that as well but it also reveals
the problem in general with secular
godless government because if the
government does not recognize any divine
authority then it becomes the divine
authority if it does not wreck
it doesn't bow before any authority
above itself then it becomes the supreme
authority in the universe and so we
worry so much about you know theocracy
we worry that if a government recognizes
God in any way whatsoever then we're
gonna have a theocracy and of course if
that's true then the United States from
the beginning has had a theocracy
because references to God and the
Creator and divinely endowed rights and
all of that that's just dripping all
over our founding documents but what we
see is that the real theocracy and the
most dangerous kind of theocracy is the
one that results from a government that
does not recognize God because then it
puts itself in God's place and it
becomes the God and it invents its own
religion and then enforces those rules
and we see I mean the entire 20th
century we've got tens and tens and tens
of millions hundreds of millions of dead
people who can testify or if they were
still alive at least could testify to
the the the great harm that is done the
great danger of these godless
governments who and say essentially
become theocratic governments because
they that because they are God and so
they get to decree and they've decreed
in this case that Alfie Evans life isn't
worth living and that the parents you
know no longer have any authority over
their child and they have decreed that
that is their sort of religious decree
not based in anything other than their
own authority which they have granted
themselves so we should pray for Alfie
Evans and we should also
for our own country that we somehow can
avoid walking down this same path
although we are already walking it
alright I'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody talk to you tomorrow